right now new at 4 30 eight inmates face
charges in connection with that prison
riot at the 8 news now investigators
first uncovered thanks for staying with
us I'm David Schantz I'm Kirsten Joyce
new court documents we've obtained
reveal more about what happened eight
news now investigators Vanessa Murphy
continuing her coverage Now Vanessa
rocks thrown at officers a broom set on
fire and thrown at them and surveillance
cameras covered up as inmates took over
a unit at Southern desert Correctional
Center initially the Nevada Department
of Corrections called what happened on
December 8th a disturbance but in May
the 8 news now investigators exposed it
was actually a riot now court documents
reveal eight inmates face charges
including rioting this was beyond a bad
situation that's what union leader Paul
lundquitz told the 8 news now
investigators earlier this year two
months after our report the warden of
the medium security prison resigned this
is the same prison where a convicted
murderer escaped in September prisons
director Charles Daniels resigned
Governor Steve sisselek said at his
request in a sit-down interview with the
8 news now investigators in October
Daniels still insisted no Riot occurred
endoc initially released this issued a
press release calling it a disturbance
and it really was a riot I'm not buying
into the fact that that was a riot I
mean how do you define a riot versus a
disturbance it was a disturbance
it yeah it was it was a disturbance four
correctional officers also faced charges
in connection with the riot Vanessa
Murphy 8 news now and a former director
Daniels insisting that he had asked the
state for help to update infrastructure
and security at the prison before recent
events